and you know my childhood hanging with
bam and all this guy I mean yeah it was
like I was like oh this is great yeah
I'd love to be a part of this so yeah
yeah wasn't it
um an audio Shoes video that you and
Tony Hawk had a double part and Bam had
a part in the same video yeah yeah well
we would go on tour together in like the
bus and it was Rowdy I mean if we talked
about the docu-series on Max
um called the last run but there's
footage of that tour in there where like
those guys definitely like broke me into
the skateboarding like they're like it
ain't gonna be easy we're gonna you know
The Hazing the like in a fun way but it
was it was you know a rowdy rowdy tour I
can't imagine Tony Hawk gets rowdy
you know at the time
um you know he had kind of the weight of
the world on his shoulders because he
was like carrying the tour you know he
was his name's on the bus he's got the
game coming out you know there's a lot
of pressure but before the game no I
couldn't have been no but you know game
number what year was that or whatever at
this point I'm trying to remember I know
it was a rarity and I was three yeah it
was like a 102. yeah because my mom let
me go solo and that was a big deal she's
like well I trust Tony Hawk he's got a
kid so he's not gonna like you know she
had trust so I was probably like
gosh I gotta say like 13 or 14 right
yeah and it was like
um
you know
just watching you know those skaters go
town to town and just tear it up and
like not only the skating was insane but
just like they would go out at night you
know I'm getting a glimpse of like this
kind of like rock and roll sort of tour
lifestyle at a young age going wow this
is this is and because the snowboarders
I feel like we're a bit more buttoned up
[Applause]
it was like okay wow this was super fun
um but yeah that was a wild time for
sure I think that you're skateboarding
is criminally overlooked and in a lot of
sense because I remember that audio
video yeah and he was like was that like
your
I mean certainly your introduction to me
it was the first time I ever heard about
you you were doing I remember 720s for
sure like uh you want a couple gold uh X
Games right yeah I mean I remember Tony
being pissed because I learned a 720
before 5 40. he's like it's not how you
gotta it's not how you do it you gotta
start here you gotta you know I'm like
well it just worked better and do I
remember that you it was like a method
720 that made it different like yeah
yeah I would I because of snowboarding I
knew spins and big errors and stuff like
that because the path pipe's like 22
feet tall we bump it down to like a
13-foot vert ramp you're like oh my God
it's tiny it feels tiny right and so you
get you know
um me being comfortable in the air and
so I always said that like my
snowboarding brought my skateboarding
the size and and just the the magnitude
of it you know big jump so we hit a jump
on a skateboard it's maybe like oh it's
like a 12 foot Gap you know snowboards
like a 90-foot job huge you know right
yeah in an Arctic blizzard you know and
then and then I feel like skateboarding
brought my snowboarding like the
technical aspect like the Precision
Because by the time I got to snow I'm
like oh my God the board just gonna stay
on my feet
what could be easier if you fall you're
falling on no well that was
it sounds comfy but it's not it's I mean
it's it's icy yeah those walls and
conditions can get pretty brutal or it
can rain the night before and it just
turns into this Frozen like oh it's it's
rough so you found snowboarding a little
bit more easy to progress in I found it
yeah I found it easier for yeah from my
My overall sort of like I just took to
it right away it was easier but
skateboarding was always that kind of
unsung thing and I'm I'm glad you
mentioned that my skate crew kind of got
overlooked because that was really hard
in the documentary because we were
trying to balance like well how much
skate how much snow and and I was like
man you guys are really we're harping
really hard on the Olympics and this in
the snow stuff but there were like a
solid nine years there where I would
hang up the snowboard and go be the top
three at every single skate competition
for you know that period of time that
was a big chunk of time and and now I
see people on Instagram who was it uh
it was Tony or uh Andy Mack posted
something he's like this was like one of
the heydays of vert skating it was a
clip of me winning one of the due tour
events and the comment below is like
dude it's got the same name as that
snowboard guy that's so weird like
no dude that's me
but uh yeah it was a yeah it's a good
time and and uh was it always vert
skating or like when you were on the uh
like the boom boom hug Jam Tony Hawk
tour were you hitting the street course
I would a little bit I got a funny story
of when I skated street because when I
my first introduction was to ramps like
I had a YMCA nearby that Tony would
frequent the Encinitas yeah it was a
legendary place and so I just got
introduced to that right away and Street
skating wasn't really
as exciting it seemed you know more
redundant and Technical and like
repetitive like I'm just gonna try this
kick flipping the street over and over
and over where the ramps I'm like oh man
I can launch something I can grind and
there's just like a whole park
designated for it and so I really took
to that and then my buddies like come
skate street with us I'm like sure
at this point I used pads my whole life
so I uh in a and we show up
we show up to the streets by it's like a
four or five stair drop and all I
remember is going okay cool I like I
Ollie this thing or try to kick flip
this thing and I'm not gonna make it so
instinctually like
I go into a knee slide I jumped a five
foot stick onto my knees probably in
shorts and everyone looked at me like oh
my God why why would you do that why I'm
just like knees are bleeding I'm like
I'm just gonna go home
you know it's just embedded in my brain
to knee slide um in a panic situation so
that kind of ended my street career
pretty quickly
the news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt wall are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now yeah